ready for action training and patrolling
making their presence known jets are
fitted with cameras to record what's
happening on the waters below it means
it's harder for Iran to target tankers
in the Gulf without getting caught on
film that matters in an information war
this aircraft carrier is also ready for
a shooting war a large part of
deterrence is the readiness that backs
that deterrence up so we're ready to
defend the US and the US interest if
called upon president Donald Trump
called upon the USS Abraham Lincoln to
deploy to this region earlier than
planned it arrived in May as tensions
escalated with Iran yet the ships so
fast did clear of the Strait of Hormuz
there are some 5,600 crew on this
carrier and about 70 different aircraft
conducting daily missions the goal is to
deter threats through maintaining an
increased presence but officers tell me
that if the call came to conduct air
strikes on Iran using aircraft like
these they wouldn't hesitate war planes
on this ship were primed to attack in
June after Iran shot down a US drone
those strikes were called off but crews
could be primed again
including a Royal Navy pilot embedded
here it's not just pilot swaps US and
British warships and aircraft share
information on threats in the region
they also share port space in Bahrain to
give you a sense of just how closely
British and US forces operate out here
I'm standing on a US patrol ship with
u.s. mine hunters behind me on a US
naval base in Bahrain right next door is
HMS affair the British naval base out
here and in the distance you can see HMS
Duncan it's a type 45 destroyer deployed
out here to help protect shipping in the
Gulf these are the first independent
images of the Royal Navy ship since it
arrived in the region last month it's
one of two British warships protecting
UK flag vessels transiting through the
Strait this officer is in charge of two
American destroyers doing a similar job
yet no other country has committed ships
this is a situation that requires time
each nation's capital has to go through
the the process of their own forced
generation and seeing what capabilities
they can can and are willing to provide
to the international maritime security
contract the politics of the iran-us
standoff make it hard for other
countries to get involved but a fifth of
the world's oil passes through the
Strait of Hormuz any disruption to
tanker traffic is a problem for everyone
for this American mine hunter it means
heightened risk the USS gladiator passed
through the Strait last month did he
have any interactions with the Iranian
forces while you were transiting through
we did we have the standard interactions
that are let's say standard to the area
there were parts where we did come into
contact visual range of some of the
Iranian vessels
we think ups yes we can see them and we
can be Paul kept transiting Iran is
certainly watching every move the u.s.
makes in these waters for now there's an
uneasy calm but these ships are clearly
equipped to respond should that change